ce soir j'ai annoncé que j'avais décidé
de mettre en place le couvre-feu couvre
feu c'est à dire l'interdiction de
sortir entre 20h et 5h du matin en tout
point de la martinique
sauf bien sûr pour les urgences
sanitaires vitales il s'agit de
renforcer la prise en compte par nos
compatriotes qui publie ci de cette
obligation du confinement qui est notre
principal sécurité contre la circulation
du virus restait chez soi reste le
maître mot pour tout le monde et nous
avons une difficulté sur le début de
soirée c'est pour ça que j'ai mis en
place dès hier la fermeture des
commerces à 19 heures ce soir le
couvre-feu
en parallèle j'ai lancé des travaux sur
les courses l'alimentation les commerces
il ya trop de monde dans les commerces
certains d'eux des personnes qui
résident ici vont faire leurs courses
plusieurs fois dans la semaine
même parfois presque tous les jours
c'est excessif c'est une mise en danger
de chacun d'entre nous donc nous devons
aussi avancer sur ces questions de
course j'ai demandé solennellement tout
à l'heure aux martiniquais zone arctique
est d'aller faire les courses une fois
par semaine et je vais lancer une
concertation avec le secteur de la
distribution et avec les maires que je
reçois jeudi pour avancer sur cette
question des courses et si nous
n'arrivons pas à faire changer les
comportements à avoir plus de discipline
entre nous sur cette question de des
courses et de l'alimentation
ce qu'on peut être obligé d'aller
jusqu'à désigner un jour par semaine
pour chaque famille pour faire ses
courses
je préférerais plutôt que mettre en
place ces mesures de coercition je
préférais pouvoir me reposer sur une
prise de conscience de chacun et le sens
des responsabilités alors de mesures de
coercition le couvre-feu vous entende
évidemment qu'il soit suivi et respecté
le couvre-feu
c'est une mesure qui est importante
parce qu'il mesure de la fin de la
journée c'est un moment particulier où
souvent après une journée de confinement
on peut être tenté de rejoindre ses amis
derrière un commerce ou chez les uns
chez les autres donc l'interdiction de
circulation
elle sera contrôlée par la police et par
la gendarmerie
tous les jours à partir de 20 heures je
demande aussi au maire de mobiliser leur
police municipale pour faire respecter
cette interdiction de circulation entre
20h et 5h du matin on s'expose à des
amendes
lorsqu'on en est ou sera pris en
infraction alors le non respect du
couvre feu sera passible d'amendés pénal
les mêmes amendes que celles qui ont
déjà été présentées pour le confinement
135 euros et en cas de récidive
deux seront 1500 euros et jusqu'à six
mois de prison mais j'espère bien que
nous n'aurons pas besoin d'aller jusque
là